la pandémie vient remettre en question
les plans de carrière de plusieurs
jeunes qui est quelqu'un moi qui étais
jamais ça valait a appelé le croissance
qui a manqué d'ailleurs des pilotes et
des avions c'est sûr ça fait quelque
chose de voir que tout s'est arrêté
la motivation aussi pour continuer
c'était difficile surtout parce
qu'évidemment on était confiné on y faut
aussi émotive ça fait beaucoup
déjà berne projet d'auto rap est
particulièrement difficile
particulièrement complexe mais il n'ya
pas que les étudiants qui ont vu leur
carrière chamboulée par la crise
sanitaire
on est un peu désorienté dans ce show
moi je me suis dit que je vends je me
posais la question c'est arrivé on sent
un peu mines en coin à la merci on
essaie de sauver des portes de sortie je
pas capable de mettre fin à 100% à ce
que je faisais mais je vois ça
positivement un nouveau comme si à
prendre cinq ans recommence à zéro peu
importe l'âge recommencer à zéro n'est
pas toujours facile
j'adorais mon travail ça a été une très
grosse déchirure avec tous ces jeunes et
moins jeunes qui sont je changeais
carrière en raison de la pandémie
l'institut national de la recherche
scientifique anticipe des jeunes hausse
des inscriptions aux cycles supérieurs
avec une période de plein emploi qui
était sans précédent dans l'histoire
récente du québec si les perspectives
d'emploi sont plus incertaines il est
fort probable que plus d'étudiants vont
décider de poursuivre des études de
maîtrise et tout ça se reflète dans les
bureaux des conseillers en orientation
du québec que plus de gens qui viennent
nous voir en évoquant le besoin ou le
goût de se réorienter à cause de la
crise
on peut pas inventer des emplois qui ne
sont pas au rendez vous en ce moment le
retour à la normale pourrait être long
pour certains types d'emplois mais les
conseillers en orientation crois qu'il
sera toujours temps de se réinventer
chacun sa façon ici alexandre les radio
canada québec